welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
why pain control is good science the
scientific rationale it is presented by
Marcel parrot genteel DVM University
veterinarian and director at the
laboratory animal resources center at
the University of Texas at San Antonio
my name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab Rhodes lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. karat genteel I
will now turn the presentation over to
him well thank you Judy for that
introduction and let's get started so
today the goal of this presentation will
be a very simple it will be will discuss
about the indirect effect of pain on
experimental results and we'll give you
some practical suggestions for the
minimization of both physical and mental
pain which both are very intricately
connected to each other so in 1655
Edmund O'Mara
said that the wretched torture of
vivisection places a body in an
unnatural state basically what dr.
O'Meara um mr. Herrera stated was that
the physiology of the animal it could be
affected by pain which in fact which
eventually will translate the results
into unreliable data they see how true
that is so what is biomedical science
biomedical science is seeking to
eliminate all potential variables so an
investigator could focus on the
objective of of the study whether that
be a behavior compound a molecule or an
injury with the goal of obtaining
consistent data and eventually a
reliable publication which is the
outcome of the vast majority of research
that is done anywhere in the world so
pain along with stress will stimulate
the HPA which stands for the
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal axis
which also stimulates the sympathetic
nervous system and these two will induce
a release of Google corticosteroids and
Kotick catecholamines which will
eventually affect behavior of the animal
autonomic nervous system the
neuroendocrine system immune and immune
system and when these systems
begin with pain and stress which which
puts into motion this cascade will
eventually result in variables and their
data so this this right here the word
data all in black is what the
investigator is looking for the
investigator is looking for here
unaltered
uniform data but what is it what happens
is that variables will make data just
mix basically if every variable will
affect really if you want to put it this
way the color of data and the outcome of
data so what are variables what are we
talking about we're talking about poorly
controlled environments or surgical
procedures surgery with that is
contaminating practices that are not
consistent in the animal facility for
example lack of solid SOPs where things
are not done the same way all the time
the presence of pathogens in the colony
the lack of certified diets and poor
micro environment and of course we know
that analgesics can affect data the
thing is that thing and of course stress
do can affect data so ideally this is
what the investigator is looking for an
investigator will love to eliminate
every single bit of variables but there
the reality is that not every single
variable can be eliminated but variables
can be minimized by doing things right
so we can focus on the objective and we
have data that is perhaps 95 percent
confidence that it is reliable what's
unacceptable is that mixed data that is
influenced strongly by variables that is
totally unacceptable so what about
treating pain or not so it is very
frequent and I'm I'm the first that
reads the protocol so my institution and
other institutions that have worked with
that are institutions that are still
worked with and they're not not
uncommonly an investigator that is
concerned about the use of penalties it
will say we can't use analgesics and and
then quotes the name of science and and
say exactly the words in the name of
science but the justification of it here
they cave all kinds of literature
citations indicating wow in this pathway
in that pathway and the center looking
at this inflammatory response and this
and that and the other will be affected
by if I buy the analgesics that are used
are intend to use so I don't want to use
analgesics and our our cooks on our
veterinarian say okay that's justified
so let's not use analgesics in this
protocol and then the animals will end
up having pain so which which one of
these which has a greatest impact on
data it's the V analgesics or is the
pain let's look at it for a little bit
okay so I know G six we know that they
can affect the immune system and the
experimental you so there's no doubt
about it no one and I'm not arguing that
at all you know this presentation but
what I can tell you is that pain results
in a cascade of physiological
neurological complicate and behavioral
effects that may make uncontrolled pain
a source of experimental response that
is a fact and we cannot deny it so well
what will pain do to the animal to the
physiology to to the well-being of the
animal so pain will affect the
sympathetic nervous systems will affect
the coronaries will will affect cardiac
output will affect the myocardium it
will increase systemic vascular
resistance blood pressure oxygen demand
and spleen ischemia I can go on and on
it will affect the kidneys will increase
aldosterone
sodium and water retention will induce
the secretion of endogenous group or
corticoids
leading to immune suppression and
delayed healing a
will affect metastases leads to
self-mutilation the animal stop grooming
and anorexia and eventually weight loss
and the animal will be in a carbolic
steak
the animal will be will have an
increased population rate lock this
custody increased platelet aggregation
interference with no more tivities and
that I died we could keep going and on
on and on but the one that I'd like to
focus on is the altered mental state and
the anxiety that the animal feels the
stress of the animal which will lead to
hyperalgesia so what is hyperalgesia I
already fun here but let me explain
hyperalgesia is they say that our
typical teen in salt will will result in
a from one to ten and they say four
point five on our scale thing before in
the skill ten pain level well
hyperalgesia is basically a pain that is
greater than that which is expected in
other words this animal instead of
having pain level four will probably
have pain love level six or seven and is
the amplification of the pain signal so
anxiety stress have the potential to
inducing Hawkgirl GZA which is really
contrary to sound practices right so
this animal right here
our contribution with this animal have
those experimental results this animal
had a surgery on the femur it's animals
not doing well and you know it really
has become Zama has become a worthless
animals had to be euthanized
so if Edwin Ameri in 1655 said that the
animal physiology could be affected by
paying which could result in too
unreliable data
if he can say that back in 1655 with
almost no basis almost I said almost
I didn't say no basis but almost on
basis because when you're compared to
the data that he can tend to what we
have today
Wow today we have plenty we have an
enormous amount of literature that
showed that the pain can affect the
animals physiology and therefore the
experimental results so typically your
investigator the one who justifies the
protocol who says that no I can't use
analgesics because it will affect
pathway a B C or D and this is how the
investigator would like to see or the
investigator views and the use of
analgesics as the Inc analgesic dose
increases so the variables however this
is the veterinarians you know this is
hard luck to see it this is how we like
to see all all pain induced research is
that as the analgesic those bulls are
but the variables will go down
eventually but what is it right you is
that the persecutor sources the
veterinarian well I don't know I say
here is a here here here here
I don't know but what I'd like to do
today and one of my goals of this
presentation it's not to give you an
answer I'll tell you you must give some
of Jesus you must have strong pain
control on every experiment because I
don't know I don't know your science I'm
not I'm just a veterinarian live on a
lunar and it was who really wants to
stick up for the animals as much as
possible but we know that given pain
control should be considered not just
this Mason I cook I want to encourage
our articles not to just stay
the investigators argument that well he
the investigator gave a series of
citations indicating how the analgesics
will affect his research with that
giving thought to the fact that and we
saw about three slides earlier that
really show and pretty much give
evidence the pain itself can affect many
of those same pathways of the analgesics
would good effect so having said that
have been giving you an argument at
least some footwork thought on the
control of pain
I believe that I think we no longer
veterinarians and I cooked need to sit
just still and take the investigators
word even though even when the
investigator gives strong citations that
analgesics need to be discounted I think
we need to really really really
reconsider our approach to pain control
again
realizing that pain may in many cases
and I would almost like to say she but I
can't prove it that in the majority of
cases and of course that is depending on
the degree of pain and the connect
chronicity of pain is that pain could
affect just about most research even
though the investigator had given pretty
strong evidence from the literature that
that the use of analgesics could be kind
of productive to research his or her
research so let's start up a little bit
about an approach a practical approach
to pain management these are my
experiences and I like to share with the
audience one is that pain is both
physical and mental even though there
are two separate topics there in circle
we spoke earlier we mentioned earlier
the concept of hyper therapy that when
an animal is under mental distress or
stress hyperalgesia
more likely to happen and induce more
physical pain so let's talk about very
briefly about pharmacological methods of
pain control this is part suggestion
part philosophy but I want to show that
what has worked for me and for your
consideration so there's some principles
I'd like to hold on one is pre-emptive
there's a post-op approach to analgesia
so if this you all remember the
controversy last year the year before
where North Korea was threatening the
United States and and the United States
was reacted onwards and concerned that
maybe there was a threat that maybe some
missiles could be launched from North
Korea all the way to reach some major
cities in the United States to say San
Francisco so let's say that North Korea
sends that missile a hits and and kills
half a million people in the city of San
Francisco well what if I'm the president
of the United States and I know that
that a missile is coming and I know that
I can prevent it I'm gonna be the first
one to launch my missiles against our
country so if I'm the president then am
i if I know it is
they're coming I'm gonna shoot them in
the air or I'm going to just go after
that nation that is being the aggressor
against my nation and that is a
pre-emptive attack and that if I let the
that missile hit the San Francisco the
losses would be great already so that
counts
thus the concept of pre-emptive
analgesia we we believe and I believe
that a hitting the enemy before the
enemy hits you is a good concept when it
comes to analgesics in other words if I
wait
finally the cigarette I'm waiting until
the animals recover him analgesia and
the animals already in pain again a
post-op and on g6 that analgesia is not
going to work as well except there I
would have given us before the insult in
other words three other so that is a
concept of pre-emptive analgesia a
multi-modal approach versus a single
analgesic is superior as well so they
mean they use a scenario of the missiles
and you know war between two countries
so they find the United States and I
know that I'm fighting against another
country I'm not by the way I'm not
promoting war and I'm just giving you
examples two illustrations and is that
I'm I'm gonna attack it from every
direction that I can't I'm gonna go to
the land and then I go through air and
then I go through the sea and I'm going
to hit the enemy from the front from the
rear and from the side on top that's a
multi-modal approach to go after the
enemy versus a single attack just land
approach so analgesia the combination of
analgesics works significantly better
when we think of a multi-modal approach
in this case you know combinations
typically of non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs with opioids and
in combination with local or regional
anesthesia
it worked wonderful because pain is
induced through many pathways and as
we're gonna discuss in just a few
minutes the non pharmacological method
is key to treat mental pain so another
concept that we need to keep it Sara
let's say buprenorphine is given you
know our zero and the levels of pain
control go up and then go down into it
and when the the pain goes down goodness
every 12 hours and when pain is are the
highest and they will just give another
dose before we give it every 12 hours
often they're not a benefit down a
but what if we consider overlapping
doses don't worry those peaks and
valleys and now the United States I know
that in many other culture in fact I
don't even know we can find this in
other countries we base our formulations
they sustain release formulations have
worked really well I'm using in my
institution because what these do is
that they provide pain control when it's
given immediately soon after it is
administered the levels go up and they
are maintained for approximately 72
hours and the two most common drugs that
are being used and lap animal in
particular in the in the United States
is meloxicam SR and buprenorphine s are
another common so the concept of
avoiding peaks and valleys is is a valid
one a by doing or continuous or
overlapping regimes as we discuss in a
graph and these sustained release
formulations I'm sorry if they're not
you can't find this and in other
countries but I understand that zoo farm
is not who is compounding form pharmacy
that produces these s or formulations
are not in other countries hopefully
they will because there is a market and
I'm pretty much at this point I am I am
treating all our animals here UTSA using
this concept of the pensar formulation
so let's discuss when we spoke about
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories we
spoke about opioids and then local
anesthesia let's talk about local
anesthesia what are the advantages of
the local anesthesia is that can reduce
that required those overall those of the
systemic analgesics so let's say that a
my analgesic multi-modal approach i give
inserts and I give opioids but we know
that every drug has is ill effects on
side effects
if I used local anesthesia I might be
able to even lower the dose and
therefore the side-effects of each one
of those and in fact anesthesia - if I'm
used to let's say isoflurane and you
know isoflurane is one of the better
anesthetics that are out there
however it's not without side effects
and issues and if I get a lot on a
static maybe if I typically keep my
animals for this particular procedure
2.5% isoflurane well maybe now I'm going
to keep it more like a 2% and local
anesthesia also minimizes the hacker
orgies again which is an amplification
of a pain signal this is what I the
concept that I use when I recommend to
our investigators the use of local
anesthesia I tell them to do an infusion
of a combination of both lidocaine and
you feel the pain the lidocaine well who
say okay well the answer not gonna need
it because ya know this water can
doesn't last long they say food but
forty minutes they the thing is that the
use of lidocaine will help that concept
that I just mentioned that maybe you can
keep that analgesia instead about 2.5
maybe two percent I don't know something
like that and lidocaine although it
doesn't work right away it takes quite a
few minutes to start working and Lance
were quite a few hours and it is in
particular this immediate post-op and in
all species but in particular abundance
that immediate post-op it's really
crucial because that is if an animal
wakes up with pain and that animals less
likely to drink and to eat and it is
that time when the catabolic state is
really you know the body is really going
downhill the quake is and we want to be
verb that if you the use of local
anesthetics
has the power it has it influences the
end
or it minimizes or brings down the pain
sensation and are in the surgical area
so that the animal postdoc can start
feeling a reversing the catabolism now
let's focus a little bit on the non
pharmacological methods of pain control
so I'm gonna ask the audience a and of
course you will need to answer because
you I'm the only one that is that can
talk here but I'm going to ask anyway
how many of you have ever had a really
severe headache like a microwave or just
a plain old very painful whatever let's
say a headache I think you know if you
look at see your your hands I'm pretty
sure that I'm gonna see just about every
hand dice them so if you if you've had a
migraine or um really really severe
headache what do you do in addition to
the wonderful miracle pill the medicine
that you take what do you do well you
wanna go lay down you wanna turn the
lights down
you tell their wife the only key to shut
up and dogs are taking about sighs hold
on here and you want the temperature to
be just right and you want to feel very
comfortable so what is what did we just
described we just described the non
pharmacological method of pain control
so does it work yeah you bet it does it
does work and and you have experience of
do but and you have applied the non
pharmacological methods of pain control
to your own well-being but when these
protocols are written how they're
written
they're written in a way that well the
investigator only describes analgesics
but where is it description of non
pharmacological methods do for pain
control so let's place let's think about
that how do we do this how do we what
are what methods are are
non-drug can we help the animal one is
aseptic technique is essential for pain
later we'll give you a link to very easy
a link to a website the libido Resources
Center where we have developed a series
of videos to help the investigator apply
aseptic technique in ways that are very
very simple to do so why
aseptic technique I wish I had time to
really build real details but it is well
documented that the infection will lead
to clinical and some clinical
subclinical means even though you think
this here you may not see the signs the
over signs of infection there is
something underneath that incision that
is subclinical and it is an infection
because it up contributes to the
inflammatory process the inflammation
leads to pain pain leads to
physiological changes of course in early
on this presentation and guess what we
are variables so fear and anxiety they
enhance the pain response we mentioned
earlier providing a stress-free
environment must be included in the pain
management program and I think it should
be discussed in protocols are we i coats
need to be asking investigators what are
you gonna do do minimize pain so I'll
give you a couple suggestions here
because suggesting you can develop your
own list but a we know that minimizing
the environmental strengths will
minimize stress induced apparel Jesus
discussed earlier so let me give you
examples so you see this one in the
middle that's called Empire Drive I'm a
new veterinarian and in Texas Tech
University and I had to travel once a
week to a facility that was about an
hour's flight away from the headquarters
Texas Tech University their headquarters
was at the Health Science Center was in
Lubbock Texas so I had to fly to El Paso
Texas to the Texas Tech University
Health Science Center El Paso
so I'm fairly new veterinarian lock on
over there this was about maybe about 14
years ago and there was doing my rounds
and I want to learn the program and then
I go into this room full of rats and and
I see rats I had been there were zuker
rats diabetic rats of bees that had been
implanted into the abdominal aorta they
had an implant to measure blood pressure
and the blood pressures measured with
our wires coming out ya know was just
done be mostly and but I go look at
these animals that are individually
housed obviously they have to be
individually housed because you have to
measure blood pressure individually of
each one of the animals so they also
played under the each cage that measure
the blood pressure of each other but
there was nothing nothing but Betty on
carpet so I go into the investigators
lamp and go meet him hello dr.
such-and-such and nice to meet you
Marcel two rather new veterinarian oh
yes
you know once we're done with all the
pleasantries I asked the doctor doctor
hey I noticed that your cages are barren
would you mind if we put some entire
drive because enrichment really helps
animals display the species specific
behavior and you know rats like to hide
in dark places and things like that I
was sure Marcel there's no problem at
all his name was Daniel and I'm not
gonna say his last name just in case it
but by the way he was very compliant
with gonna cooperate a great individual
too and so from the point on we put a
guard right into the cages well a few
months go by and I run into Danielle
into in the hallway and
he stopped in so my cell my cell got
about you and said oh sure how are you
what's going on myself ever since we
implemented the embargoing to back
Katie's the mean blood pressure has
brought between 10 and 20 points
I said Marcel my data has improved
unbelievably well
wow that's great then you know I'm so
happy to hear that so as a result of
that we we did a poster and we print
senator one of the meetings and and
that's a great story I think let me give
you one more story this little Hut right
there the red hot you know that Martin
Brant can't see through the red spectrum
and so I a few years ago I sent email
the power
investigators are breeding animals and I
tell them investigators from this
starting on such a such a day we're
going to place these huts facing the red
face in the front of the cage and all
breeders all breeding cages and nobody
objected sure you're not additional
enrichment so a few months go by and
then I get a email from one of the
investigators and the best together
tells you myself this has worked really
well for us
because ever since before we implemented
a the huts my rats were producing about
but six pups were for birth now after
and after the Red Hots now they're
producing they're doubling that so I
said wow that's a really good success so
what happens what did we do with these
animals we enrich the environment we
manage the stress because now that they
were not as bored they they're the mice
and the rats and had the red hot perhaps
and we're not able to see their
personnel all the monsters are working
in front of the the cages under scaring
them so perhaps the embryos were not
being reabsorbed then so you minimize
environmental stress really
does work although the Red Hots scenario
has nothing to do with pain it is also
applicable because it really brought
down the environmental stress of these
animals so what about tasty calories so
we we use we're use 15 leave these dye
gels and also this bacon some peas and
that are very delicious to our rodents
and there are full of energy and
remember we talked about earlier about
the rats and the minds that wake up from
surgery and then they are they need to
eat right away we talked about the local
anesthesia as a way to really help me
right away well it does work but also if
we can just give them very tasty
calories then the atoms are more likely
to give up I give it a couple of
examples where we were doing I was doing
these few more implants we took about
half a centimeter of the femur and would
put implants we put bone plates and
that's a very painful procedure of
course we cover them with good systemic
local and systemic analgesics but
nonetheless the animals will kind of
wake up and you know a fair amount of
pain while these rats like this diet gel
so much that the atoms are still
recumbent unable to stand up all the big
deal was just to move their their heads
a little bit and they were just laughing
the dye job even while the animals were
semi-conscious so there is a company
that I work for is called wellness
entertain birthday so this company and
we have animals that are under chemo and
they have tumors induced and you know
what happens with cancer the patient
stops eating they become really skinny
and in the case of lab animal the
protocol calls for endpoint so the
animals will really lose in a lot of
weight and they were reaching their
endpoints because
the weight lost about 30% of the weight
loss and we argued and I said well but
then we did we started putting this
bacon softest and the bottom of the cake
is these animals that have refused to
eat because of either they keep on the
cancer now they wanted to eat and I
start to gain weight and then this time
instead of being lost and that data
being lost to euthanasia to the
endpoints now we were able to obtain
data from these animals what about
social housing social housing is crucial
because they learn and and I've seen so
many protocols that the investigator
will say no we can't use we can use we
have to house the animals individually
because they're gonna pick on each other
suture well my approach now is you have
evidence but we have we know we have
evidence that rats and mice that are
housed like rats are with a spinal cord
injury and recover much better when they
were when there were group housing with
the word individually housed and minds
with telemetric implants a day when they
were housed socially they recover better
so social housing even post-op it's an
automatic illogical method pain control
and animals recover better when they're
housed together
post-op so yeah the investigator will
tell me yeah but I've seen them pick up
each other sutures well how many animals
have you done I have done hundreds of
cert of these surgeries and how many
times have you seen this happen one or
twice well even in that case I think we
as an article you need to challenge
investigator said well what about for
the sake of all those other hundreds
implement the social housing even even
at the risk of maybe there one or two of
the three that may pick at each other
see something to think about what are
they known for Mike logic
methods of pain control a one is
habituation to procedures a the dim
lines remember the when you have a
headache that didn't live in the lights
in the room with a deal good for you in
the same way with Lauren noise you did
not want to hear the dog you didn't want
to hear the kids scream and a lot of
people have long you know these watts of
keys and and this metal cage card
holders sometimes it fall to the floor
and the animal holding room and you know
the cost stress on people are talking
laughs I think when we work in the
animal holding boots we should really
minimize or at least lower our voices
prion fluids are crucial we have seen in
fact we require of our investigators
poster pre-op that all mice and rats are
given fluid therapy and that decreases
and hence increased morbidity mortality
and I that is a method that will really
save and really improve the recovery of
many many many animals there no support
hypothermia has a tremendous negative
impact on the animal and acclamation is
crucial as well
so why acclamation why do we need to
implement implement well if you purchase
if you place an order for your minds
they say Charles River
what does Josue ever do they receive the
order they go to the animal holding room
these animals have been housed all their
lives in this particular case with this
particular bed the technician goes and
picks a few the animals that were
ordered and they put them in this
cardboard box filtered it's a new kind
of box new kind of way of feeding
different lights and all that they place
the animals then carried they're taken
into a truck the truck is a diesel truck
and this vibrating and the smell and
then next day they're gonna travel all
night or couple night and then they get
to the new facility may hear different
voices somebody talking about it whether
in the hallway
and then their place the animator place
and the animal hole boom moon lights a
new everything new food new sounds new
experiences new smells new cage new
bedding I think this animal by the time
this animal arrived to the institution
it's an it's mighty unhappy amicus nest
is this the animal that I want to use
for my experiments I don't think so
that's why acclamation is key and
definitely different institutions have
different different days of Reclamation
some have 72 hours some will have a
weeks will have longer than that but
some sort of acclamation to the new
environment is key before the
experiments are are implemented and of
course this is what we want to start
with this happy animal that is a stress
free as possible that is really ready to
undergo explain an experimental
procedure so in summary we must consider
the indirect effect of pain on
experimental result and not just take
the investigators word even literature
citation to really prove his or her
point that analgesics cannot be used and
we must transport the physical and the
mental pain so this is it for this
presentation and here's the website that
I'm gonna leave it here for if you want
to see we have a lot of resources a lot
of materials that a lot of people use in
throughout the world and in particular
for surgery we have a number of surgical
procedures detailed in here and in
particular that the aseptic surgery that
has been so difficult for investigators
to implement we have implemented here we
have shown we have a series of videos to
really make a septa technique a lot much
easier to do
plus we have handouts on greening
diagnostic sheets of if you have green
flowers that etc etc certified
methodology at all so that concludes my
presentation and I thank you for
attending and I hope I can meet some of
you Sunday in the
near future thank you doctor parrot
genteel for that informative
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 27th 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time bye